hey guys how's it goin welcome back to
my kitchen it's been a while since I've
cooked anything for you guys so I
thought I'd do something a little bit
special as we all know it's pumpkin
spice latte season dude dude dude dude
so I'm gonna make a pumpkin spice latte
cake dude dude dude dude turndowns PS oh
alright so first steps first we're gonna
make our cake I've got this wonderful
box here that will make the cake I've
got to set my oven to 350 Fahrenheit
it's already preheating so we're set to
go as always here in iJustine z--
kitchen we only use the finest blenders
when we cook don't you just get role in
there okay egg time three three eggs
shoot one two three oh man I got a egg
everywhere if I was a third cup of oil I
would probably be like that much we
don't measure here
Oh so instead of a cup of water we're
gonna use a pumpkin spice latte instead
it's only natural but we do just sorts
of things here here we go in those PSL I
have no idea who's gonna work on cuz the
lid
looks a little a little watery I'm a
little nervous
blend cake in large bowl until moistened
beat with mixer on meat for two minutes
how long do I beat it if it's in a
blender I think that's a 13 by 9 pan a
34 to 38 minutes holy moly I ain't got
that kind of time here's our cake you
look fabulous
so you look fabulous hmm into the oven
we go what's hot all righty then our
next step is gonna be making icing I've
never actually made icing before but I
thought it would be pretty easy cuz it
looks like there's one whole step
combined icing mix and softened butter
in a mixing bowl we don't use mixing
bowls here mmm smells good well grow
mice so we need to soften the butter
stick you in the microwave that's how we
do oh I can't see the butter anymore ah
it's gross it's pretty disgusting I have
a feeling this is not gonna blend Wow
shorty got low low low yeah got those
apple bottom jeans and boots with the
food
this is this icing what the hell am I
making
mm-hmm there all right we'll let you
cool off a little bit and then we're
gonna do a little bit of decorating and
then the taste test all right it's time
to decorate we're just gonna do a real
simple frosting because that's uh
I thought god I didn't think this is
gonna be enough I'm not even sure let's
oh my gosh it's still hot no look onto
the cake
honestly Rachael Ray she's gonna be like
Justine I saw your video you're
brilliant you're the best cook in the
world I think that you should uh oh no
this is all chunky Oh God
I retract everything the Rachael Ray was
saying to me because she's gonna say
Justine you're terrible you're pathetic
this looks like glue this looks actually
disgusting
whatever this icing is I will never ever
buy it again okay no oh God the whole
top of my cake is coming on why you
gotta be so rude don't you know it I'm
not good at cooking food
there's no point in decorating us
there's no point in wasting any more
resources or time on this cake here you
go this is my pumpkin spice latte cake
cheers to you guys thanks for watching
make sure you guys like this video if
you want to see more let me know in the
comments below what you would like me to
cook next hopefully I won't screw it up
I do have a feeling this is gonna taste
quite tasty so let's up serve it up
sorry cake you're not even worthy of an
actual plate here we go
I'm not really sure I think it's good it
tastes nice but something doesn't seem
textural even correct better luck next
time
Justine